ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BAKER
GORGEOUS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTESE DALLY DODD THE RAZA
EGGMAN GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG
HUESO HURTADO JONES LAYARD
LEYVA MCGUIRE MELENDEZ IN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF VOGUE.
PAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER AMBERG WHY CASKEY
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WILL BE LET THIS MORNING IN
PRAYER BY SENATOR PAN FTER
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY
REMAIN STANDING. AND WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BY SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU-
SENATORS TODAY THE WORLD BEGINS
THE LUNAR NEW YEAR AND USHERS
IN THE YEAR OF THE OX. AND THE
SEND PARABLE OF THE TEN BOWLS
AND OXFORD RESEARCH FIRST
LOSTOCK SERVES AS A PARABLE FOR
PRACTITIONERS PURSUIT OF
ENLIGHTENMENT. AND SO WE PRAY.
CREATIVE MYSTERY OF THE
UNIVERSE LIKE THE OX HERDER.
DILIGENTLY FOR THAT BALL OUR
TRUE NATURE MAYBE BE ATTENTIVE
TO THE SIGNS AND FOOTPRINTS OF
THE BOWL. MAY WE SEEK HIM OUT
WE CATCH A GLIMPSE OF THE BASIC
PRESENCE. MAY WE NOT ONLY
OBSERVE THE NAY WE HAVE THE
COURAGE AND STRENGTH TO CATCH
THE BALL. THEY RETAIN THE BALL
WITH PATIENCE AND DETERMINATION.
MAYBE RIDE THE BULL HOME THE
TUNE TO THE MUSIC OF OUR
SUCCESS. HAVING RETURNED TO OUR
SOURCE WHEN WE ABANDON THE NEED
TO WRESTLE WITH THE BALL. AND
THEN WE REST AND SERENITY AND
REPOSE. AND ARE TRANSCEND
SENTENCE OF SELF. MAY WE NO
LONGER NEED EVEN IN LIGHT. MAY
WE SEE THAT THE RIVER FLOWS
TRANQUILITY AND THE FLOWERS ARE
RED WITHOUT OUR INTERVENTION.
MAY WE RETURN TO THE WORLD
KNOWING ALL THIS ONE. AS WE
BRING ENLIGHTENMENT TO OTHERS.
EIGHTY NINE. MY COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. ISRAEL STRONG.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. MEMBERS
TODAY WILL HAVE SENATORS BATES
BLAZER LAMONT IN STERN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY GOOD
MORNING SENATORS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION. MOVING ON
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS FROM COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION OF THE FIRST
READING OF BILLS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY NINE AND
SENATE BILL FOUR HUNDRED. THANK
YOU. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE HAVE GOVERNMENT GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR APPOINTMENTS SIR WHAT
WERE YOU PREPARED FOR THOSE
ITEMS ONE IN. FIVE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE IS A CONFIRMATION OF CARLA
VISTA AND COULD STAND AS-
CASTENADA AS CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR OPERATIONS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES PRIOR TO THIS
APPOINTMENT SHE WAS SERVING AS
THE ASSISTANT PROGRAM BUDGET
MANAGER FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY
THIRD RD UNANIMOUS FIVE A VOTE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. ANY FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT.
HERNING SHE NINE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA ATKINS I BAKER.
HI FORGES I BRADFORD I CAN BY
ADAM. CORTESE I DALLY. DALLY.
DODD HI I TORONTO. I EGGMAN.
FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH MMHM. I
DON'T SEE HER SO. EARNS NOW L.
GROVE. HERTZBERG HI HUESO BY
HER TADO. JONES I LAYERED I
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE. HI MELENDEZ I
MEN I NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN BY A
SHOW OF BOTH. HI PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO. I
SKINNER HI STERN. AMBERG HI MY
CASKEY. FIVE WIENER I WILK HI
MA'AM SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. BY ADAM. I DALLY. I
GROVE. HURTADO STERN. CLOSE
ROTELLA DEVOTES FIVE THIRTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED CENTER IN THE WORLD
FILE I'M FIVE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF LOWER
RANKING AND AARON STOCKWELL TO
THE BANKING STANDARDS
COMMISSION BOTH OF THESE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED ON A
FIVE OH VOTE IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE THIRD OF
FEBRUARY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. RIGHT ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THE APPOINTMENT. HEARING C.
NINE MINUTES SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ONE ITEM FILE
ITEM FIVE. ALLEN I ARCHULETA.
ATKINS I BAKER. FIVE BARGES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM I
PRETENDING I ALLEY I DODD. HI
TERRADO I EGGMAN. I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG HI HUESO. I
FURTADO JONES I LAYERED I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ I MEN HI
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A SHOW OF
VOGUE. I PAN FIVE PORTANTINO. I
ROTH I RUBIO. HI SKINNER I
STERN. AMBERG I WHAT KIND OF
SKI HI WIENER HI WILK. HI FOR
JUST I'D- MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL UP MEMBERS WILL GET FOR
FOSTER CARE CLOSE ROLE TELLING
VOTE HIGHS THIRTY TWO NO ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
MOVING ON NOW MEMBERS TO SENATE
THIRD READING. WE HAVE FIVE
ITEMS FIRST UP IS FILE ITEM.
NINE ITEM NINE. ARE WE PREPARED
FOR THAT ITEM. SENATOR ALTHOUGH.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIFTY ONE BY
SENATOR DORADO AND AFTER
LEADING TO SUPER SURPLUS
PROPERTY IN DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR ALSO THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT. SB
FIFTY ONE THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL COST SAVINGS
FOR THE STATE. OR PRODUCING A
MODEL TO EXPAND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND ENHANCE
HOMEOWNERSHIP. THIS BILL ALIGNS
WITH GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
EXECUTIVE ACTIONS TO FOSTER
HOUSING INNOVATIONS ON EXCESS
STATE OWNED LAND. FOR OVER
SIXTY YEARS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DISPLAYS THE
FAMILIES WHO LIVED IN WHAT IS
CALLED THE SEVEN TEN CORD OR-
TO BUILD A FREE WAY THROUGH THE
CITIES OF LA PASADENA SOUTH
PSADENA. IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ARE LEGISLATURE DECLARED
NO FREEWAYS WOULD BE BUILT. WE
INTRODUCED SB FIFTY ONE TO
IMPLEMENT A FAIR PROCESS FOR
TENANTS TO BUY THEIR HOMES AND
TO BRING MORE AFFORDABLE LONG
TERM HOUSING TO EL SERENO. MANY
PROPERTIES HAVE BEEN SITTING
VACANT AND IN DISREPAIR FOR
YEARS IN THE MIDST OF THE WORST
HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY. THIS BILL WILL GIVE
CURRENT TENANTS THE FIRST RIGHT
TO PURCHASE THE HOME IF THEY'RE
NOT INTERESTED OR ABLE IT
REQUIRES A PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
HOUSING RELATED ENTITY. WHO
PURCHASES THE PROPERTY PROVIDED
FOR LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
RENTAL HOUSING FOR AT LEAST
FIFTY FIVE YEARS. THIS HOUSING
RELATED ENTITIES COULD BE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR NONPROFIT
HOUSING ENTITIES. WHO WOULD BUY
THE PROPERTIES AT THE ORIGINAL
PRICE IN EXCHANGE. BROUGH
REMODELING PRESERVING
AFFORDABILITY AND MAINTAINING
THEM. VACANT PROPERTIES ALSO
WOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE
IMMEDIATELY UNDER THIS COMMON.
RENTAL THE CURRENT LAWS
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND IS NOW OVER
THIRTY YEARS OLD. IT SETS THE
ORDER OF SALES BUT DOES NOT
CREATE LONG TERM AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING. IF VACANT
PROPERTIES WERE TO GO THROUGH
THE EXISTING PROCESS THEY WOULD
BE AUCTIONED OFF AND ULTIMATELY
OPENED UP TO THE HIGHEST
BIDDER. A RECIPE FOR
GENTRIFICATION AND
DISPLACEMENT. THIS BILL WAS
DEVELOPED AFTER HUNDREDS OF
HOURS OF CONVERSATIONS AND
MEETINGS WITH RESIDENTS
ADVOCATES TENDANCE LA CITY
COUNTY OFFICIALS. AND TCHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS. ALBEIT SOME WITH
OPPOSING VIEWS. YOU CAN ONLY
IMAGINE THAT AFTER SIXTY YEARS
OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT THE LEVELS
OF LEGITIMATE ANGER FRUSTRATION
AND FEARS. THAT EXIST IN MY
COMMUNITY OR I HAVE REPORT
RESIDED OVER THIRTY YEARS. I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR
PORTANTINO ON THE PRO TEM FOR
THE GUIDANCE ON THE POLICY
COMMITTEE CHAIR MEMBERS FOR
THEIR SUPPORT. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING
NONE THIS IS CANDIDATE IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
ABUSING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THE SIDE OF. HEARING SEEN
NINE. ICE THIRTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
ON THE URGENCY ALL EYES THIRTY
TWO NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU. MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM TEN SENATOR
PAN. ARE YOU PREPARED. OKAY ARE
YOU EXCITED ABOUT SIX THIRTY
PLEASE READ THAT'S RIGHT.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHT BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE
TO THE LUNAR NEW YEAR. CENTER
PLAN THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
SENATORS- AS CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS IT IS MY HONOR TO
PRESENT S C. R. EIGHT AND
RECOGNITION OF LUNAR NEW YEAR.
I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
THIS CHAMBER- THANKS TO
LEADERSHIP MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
SAC- FROM SAN FRANCISCO-
ACTUALLY WE'VE ESTABLISHED
LUNAR NEW YEAR AS A- HOLIDAY OF
SIGNIFICANCE HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. IN FACT- THE NEW
pTWELFTH- WHERE WE WELCOME THE
YEAR OF THE OX WHICH SIGNIFIES
HARD WORK DUTY IN THIS POST
DISCIPLINE. THE YEAR OF THE OX
MARKS THE SECOND OF THE TWELVE
YEARS THAT HE ACTS LIKE ALL.
THOSE BORN UNDER THIS ANIMAL
SIGN ARE KNOWN FOR THEIR
TENACITY AND PERSEVERANCE AND I
THINK THOSE ARE TWO
CHARACTERISTICS WE CAN
PARTICULARLY USES WHAT KIND AND
THE PANDEMIC. THE LUNAR NEW
YEAR IS OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZED
AGAIN AS I SAID AT THE OF
SPECIAL SIGNIFICANCE BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS A RESULT
OF LEGISLATION THAT WE PASSED
HERE. AND TO MANY ASIAN
AMERICANS AND OUR STATE LUNAR
NEW YEAR IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT HOLIDAYS OF THE YEAR.
AND ALTHOUGH THIS YEAR. MANY
FAMILIES WILL ONLY BE ABLE TO
CELEBRATE WITHIN THEIR OWN
HOUSEHOLDS. I WANT TO SHARE
SOME TRADITIONS. ASSOCIATED
WITH THE NEWYEAR THAT FAMILIES
WILL STILL BE PRACTICING. SO
TODAY- YOU WILL RECEIVE A-
POLYA TYPE AMENITIES- ALSO
KNOWN AS A CHINESE MONEY PLANT-
COMPLIMENTS OF THE EIGHTY AYE
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS ALTHOUGH
MONEY DOES NOT GROW ON THIS
PLANT IT IS WORTH SPENDING SOME
TIME ON. IT IS HAPPY EVENTUALLY
REWARD YOU WITH WHITE FLOWERS
ON IT TANDS. YOU ALSO SEE THE
CHINESE CHARACTER FU PRINTED ON%
THE PLANT STATE. VOTE MEANS
GOOD FORTUNE BLESSINGS ARE LOCK
THIS CHARACTERS COMMONLY SEEN
ON RED ENVELOPES DOORS AND
WINDOWS AND OTHER NEW YEAR
DECORATIONS TO BRING PEACE AND
FORTUNE. INTO THE HOUSEHOLD.
THIS WEEKEND AS WE RING IN THE
YEAR OF THE OX I INVITE YOU TO
WEAR SOME RED FOR GOOD LUCK. IN
ORDER SOME DUMPLINGS AND
NOODLES OR YOUR FAVORITE DISHES
FROM YOUR LOCAL ASIAN
RESTAURANTS TO CELEBRATE THE
NEW YEAR AND HELP SUPPORT OUR
LOCAL ASIAN. RESTAURANT
BUSINESSES. SO PLEASE JOIN THE
ACHE I LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND
WISHING. EVERY CALIFORNIAN A
HEALTHY AND PROSPEROUS NEW YEAR
BY VOTING I. N. STR EIGHT.
THANKS VERY MUCH AND- SO I
STATION IN KUALA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR ROSA. YES MR PRESIDENT-
I RISE AS CHAIR OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS BUT ALSO BECAUSE IN MY
OWN DISTRICT AT LEAST SIX
HISTORICALLY RECOGNIZED API
COMMUNITIES- ARE LOCATED THAI
TOWN KOREATOWN FILIPINO IN
CHINATOWN I TRUST MANY BIKE
CONSTITUENTS WILL BE
CELEBRATING TONIGHT VERY SAFELY
I WISH YOU GOOD HEALTH AND
PROSPERITY TO ALL OUR FAMILY
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS. THANK
YOU. Q. SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF
STR EIGHT RECOGNIZING THE LUNAR
NEW YEAR YEAR OF THE OX THE OX
REPRESENTS CELESTIAL AND
EARTHLY YOU'LL EARTHLY BEINGS
IN THE RACE TO DETERMINE WHICH
CREATURES WOULD REPRESENT THE
NAME SIX OF THE TWELVE YEAR
CYCLE THE OX WHO WAS LARGE
POWERFUL AND ADAPT CARRY THE
RED ON HIS BACK THE RIGHT
JUMPED OFF AT THE FINISH LINE
IN ORDER TO CROSS FIRST. I
DON'T WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
MANY WOMEN WHO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OUR ECONOMY OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY THESE NOTABLE WOMEN.
ANNA MAY WONG FROM LOS ANGELES.
CHINESE AMERICAN ACTRESS PUT IT
BEST DRESSED WOMEN IN NINETEEN
THIRTY FOUR SPOKE COULD GET
AGAINST DISCRIMINATION. OF
CHINESE ACTRESSES. CECILIA
CHEUNG FROM SAN FRANCISCO ASIAN
TRANSGENDER WOMAN WHO'S LIVING
WITH HIV HAS SPENT HER LIFE
FIGHTING AGAINST DISCRIMINATION
STIGMA AND VIOLENCE AMONG
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. AND
CHEN CHUNG WHO. CHINESE BORN
AMERICAN EDUCATED PHYSICIST WHO
WORKED ON THE MANHATTAN PROJECT
IT WAS THE FIRST FEMALE
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
PHYSICAL SOCIETY THROUGH THEM
WE WILL CELEBRATE A SUCCESSFUL
AND HEALTHY HAPPY LUNAR NEW
YEAR. THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ. SENATOR WILK. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHT WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE LUNAR NEW YEAR
CELEBRATION AND RINGS IN THE
YEAR OF THE OX TODAY MARKS THE
BEGINNING OF A WEEK LONG
CELEBRATION ALSO KNOWN AS THE
SPRING FESTIVAL THIS IS THE
LARGEST AND MOST IMPORTANT
HOLIDAY CELEBRATED IN VARIOUS
ASIAN COUNTRIES INCLUDING CHINA
TAIWAN AND VIETNAM. WELL THE
CELEBRATION THIS YEAR IS
DIFFERENT DUE TO THE PANDEMIC I
WISH ALL MY FRIENDS AND THOSE
WHO CELEBRATE THE LUNAR NEW
YEAR A YEAR FILLED WITH MUCH
SUCCESS PROSPERITY AND
LONGEVITY. UNFORTUNATELY AS
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS CELEBRATE
THE LUNAR NEW YEAR THIS WEEKEND
MANY ASIAN AMERICAN FAMILIES
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT REPORTS OF
AN UP TICK IN CRIMES TARGETING
MEMBERS OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
I CONDEMN THE LATEST INCIDENTS
OF ANTI ASIAN VIOLENCE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND CALL ON EVERYONE
TO SUPPORT S. C. R. A. THANK
YOU. SENATOR WORK SENATOR RUBIO.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE THANK YOU. TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO FOR
PRESENTING THIS CRITICAL
RESOLUTION HONORING LUNAR NEW
YEAR AND THE YEAR OF THE OX
PEOPLE BORN UNDER THIS SIGN AT
THE OCT SEVEN HONEST NATURE AND
ARE KNOWN FOR DILIGENCE
DEPENDABILITY STRENGTH AND
DETERMINATION. I AM THANKFUL TO
HAVE BEEN A PART OF SO MANY
CELEBRATIONS IN MY DISTRICT
HONORING THIS IMPORTANT
TRADITION. CELEBRATIONS LIKE
THESE REMIND US THAT DESPITE
THE ON GOING CHALLENGES WE CAN
STILL FIND OCCASIONS TO GATHER
AND CELEBRATE CELEBRATE
IMPORTANT TRADITIONS. AND ON
THIS STATE I ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUES AND EVERYONE
LISTENING TO PLEASE SUPPORT
LOCAL ASIAN RESTAURANTS AND
BUSINESSES HAPPY LUNAR NEW YEAR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
MAN. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
GOOD MORNING AND HAPPY LUNAR
NEW YEAR TO FILL MEMBERS HERE
THIS IS THE YEAR OF THE OX AND
I AM HOPEFUL THAT THIS YEAR
WILL SEE THE STRENGTH AND
ENDURANCE OF THE OX AS WE TRY
TO GET OUT OF THE CUPBOARD
PANDEMIC. AS A KOREAN AMERICAN
AND MEMBER OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE LUNAR NEW
YEAR HOLIDAY WHICH IS
CELEBRATED BY A WIDE ARRAY OF
DIVERSE ASIAN COMMUNITIES BOTH
AROUND THE WORLD AND IN OUR
STATE. I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION PARTICULARLY AT
A TIME WHEN MANY API'S ACROSS
OUR STATE RE FEELING SCARED
AND UNWELCOME DO THE ALARMING
RISE IN HATE CRIMES AGAINST
ASIAN AMERICANS. THIS
RESOLUTION SIGNALS OUR BODY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE RICH
CULTURAL CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR
API COMMUNITIES AND I HOPE WILL
PROVIDE COMFORT TO THEM AS THEY
KNOW THAT WE CELEBRATE AND
HONOR OUR API CONSTITUENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON S. C. R. A. THANK YOU
FOR READING CENTER MINSITER
WINNER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I RISE AS- A VICE CHAIR OF THE-
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS- AND
ALSO THE SENATOR WHO
REPRESENTS. NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF ASIAN
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER.
COMMUNITY IN SUPPORT OF STR
EIGHT- WE ARE- IN THE
INCREDIBLY- DIFFICULT- TIME IN
THE COMMUNITY I THINK A LOT OF
US ARE VERY SAD THAT WE WILL
NOT HAVE- SAN FRANCISCO'S
AMAZING LUNAR NEW YEAR. OPERATE
THIS YEAR WITH OF ALONG WITH
PRIDE OR THIRD SORT OF OUR TWO
TWIN TOWERS. IN TERMS A MAJOR
COMMUNITY CELEBRATION BUT I
KNOW. THE NEXT YEAR WE WILL BE
BACK IN PERSON CELEBRATING
TOGETHER. AS A COMMUNITY- I DO
WANT TO ALSO- TO. EMPHASIZE THE
SOLIDARITY THAT WE NEED WITH
OUR- IS AN CIVIC UNDER-
NEIGHBORS IN TERMS OF THE-
VIOLENT HATE CRIMES THAT ARE
BEING. COMMITTED PARTICULARLY
AGAINST OUR- SENIORS WE SEEM TO
IN THE BAY AREA AND ELSEWHERE-
PARTICULARLY CHINESE SENIORS
WHO WERE. BEING TARGETED BUT
OTHERS AS WELL IT IS. JUST
BEYOND- DESPICABLE- AND IT YOU
KNOW I THINK WE NEED TO ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS RESULTS.
FROM SOME OF THE HEAT THAT HAS
BEEN- SPEWED- AROUND COAL BIT
AND BLAMING. MEMBERS OF OUR-
API COMMUNITY- FOR SOMEHOW
BEING RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
WHICH IS. BOB FALLS AND- VERY
VERY DESTRUCTIVE IN SO MANY
DAHLE PUSHED BACK. AND HE
CRIMES. HAPPY NEW YEAR SPENDING.
BY LOCAL HAVE A CHOICE. THANK
YOU. TO AKAKA. THIS IS MY
DESERVE MY. YOU MIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A- GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS STOP THE
ORIGINAL CITIES IT WAS A CITY
BEFORE CALIFORNIA WAS A STATE
AND WHAT THAT IS HAD A LONG
HISTORY OF BEING OPEN ARMS TO
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES WHO HAD A
STRONG INFLUENCE FROM OUR
CHINESE COMMUNITY ARE JAPANESE
COMMUNITY AND THEN OUR FILIPINO
COMMUNITY WHO WAS VERY INVOLVED
IN THE FARMWORKER MOVEMENT. AS
WE KNOW. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE STOCKTON WAS ALSO THE HOME
OF THE FIRST SCHOOL SHOOTING.
IN BUT IN WHICH FIVE SCHOOL
CHILDREN WERE KILLED FOR ALL
API IT WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
HATE CRIMES OR SOMEBODY WENT ON
A SCHOOL CAMPUS BECAUSE THEY
WERE UPSET. WITH NEW
IMMIGRANTS. AND SHOT THIRTY TWO
PEOPLE KILLING FIVE CHILDREN.
MY FRIEND WAS A KINDERGARTNER
AT THAT TIME AND SHE RECALLS
THE TEACHER LAYING ON THE FLOOR
WITH YOUR FEET UP AGAINST THE
DOOR AS THEY ALL HID UNDER
THEIR DESKS AND THE SOUND OF
GUNFIRE ALL AROUND THE SCHOOL.
WE FIND OURSELVES AGAIN IN A
SITUATION LIKE THAT WITH THE
VIOLENCE THAT IS OCCURRING WITH
OUR API COMMUNITIES. AND THEN
AS A NOW WE MUST LAY DOWN LIKE
AN OX AND PUT OUR FEET UP
AGAINST THAT DOOR TO. KEEP OUT
THE VIOLENCE TO KEEP ABOUT THE
HATE. AND TO MAKE EVERYBODY
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES FEEL
PROTECTED- AS WE GO INTO THIS
THIS WEEKEND. I WILL HAVE A LOT
OF TIME HOPEFULLY TO. TO EAT
AROUND THE PAN ASIAN MENU AND
SUPPORT OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
AND I'D ALSO BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THE FANTASTIC
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR- SOUTH
ASIAN COMMUNITIES WITH THE SIX
COMING IN IN THE FARMING
RICHNESS. AS THEY CONTINUE ALSO
TO FACE. THE KITCHEN SO LET US
ALL CONTINUE TO RISE TOGETHER.
AS WE CELEBRATE THIS NEW YEAR
AS WE CELEBRATE A NEW
BEGINNING. AND GO FORWARD
TOGETHER. THAT WOULD LIBERTY
AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. CHOI THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. KERN JINAN
CENTER PAM WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND I JUST THINK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE SPOKENON
THIS RESOLUTION AND YOUR
EXPRESSIONS OF SOLIDARITY- YOU
KNOW THE LAST YEAR THE YEAR OF
THE RAT HAS BEENA VERY
DIFFICULT YEAR FOR THE API
COMMUNITY. I'M NOT OF COURSE
ALL OF US ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THAT COVETED- AND THE PANDEMIC
BUT EIGHTY AYE BUSINESSES HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED- BECAUSE OF-
DISCRIMINATION- APPRECIATE- THE
RECOGNITION OF THE- I'M GOING I
HATE CRIMES ARE BEING COMMITTED
IT'S- COMMITTEE GUESS THE API
COMMUNITY. EVEN UP TO NOW-
WHICH IS BEEN VERY TROUBLING
AND I WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
THE MINORITY LEADER AND OTHERS
OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
MENTIONED THAT. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY HOPEFULLY TO TURN A
NEW LEAF- AS- WE CELEBRATE
BEGAN THE YEAR OF THE OX. AND
AGAIN- URGE YOU ALL TO- WELL WE
ALL CAN'T GATHER TOGETHER TO
CELEBRATE THIS WONDERFUL
HOLIDAY SUPPORT OUR LOCAL ASIAN
BUSINESSES. AND APPRECIATE THAT
YOU SPEAK OUT AGAINST THOSE WHO
WOULD SEEK TO TARGET THE API
COMMUNITY UNJUSTLY- AS WELL SO.
AGAIN SO I THINK EVERYONE AND
URGENT AYE VOTE ON- S. ON THIS
S. C. R. EIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN.
MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN. HERE IN CHINO
I THIRTY TWO NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON NOW
TO FILE ITEM ELEVEN SENATOR
RUBIO ARE YOU PREPARED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINE BY
SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION MONTH. SENATOR RUBIO
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT S. C.
R. NINE WHICH PROCLAIMS
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE S.
TEEN DATING VIOLENCE AWARENESS%
AND PREVENTION MONTH. THIS
RESOLUTION ENCOURAGES ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO OBSERVE TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION MONTH WITH PROGRAMS
AND ACTIVITIES THAT RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT TEEN VIOLENCE
THIS WEEK I PARTICIPATED IN THE
ORANGE DAY RALLY WHERE
INSPIRATIONAL YOUNG LEADERS
SHARE THEIR PERSONAL STORIES OF
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE. AND
ARE TRULY COMMITTED TO TRYING
TO PREVENT VIOLENCE FOR
THEMSELVES AND- THIRTEEN-
COLLEAGUES THIS ISSUE AFFECTS
EVERYONE NOT JUST TEENS THEIR
PARENTS THEIR TEACHERS THEIR
FRIENDS AND ENTIRE COMMUNITIES.
TEEN DATING VIOLENCE IS A VERY
SERIOUS AND GROWING PROBLEM IN
THIS COUNTRY AND WE KNOW ALL
THE PANDEMIC HAS PUT A
DISTURBING SPOTLIGHT ON
INCREASING DATING VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
PROGRAMS ENSURE A POSITIVE. THE
POSITIVE A CLIMATE AND SAFE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
TEENS WE MUST SUPPORT OUR TEENS
EDUCATE THEM ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS AND UP
LEFT THOSE WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
VIOLENCE SO THAT THEY MAY HEAL
AND MOVE FORWARD. WE MUST
ENSURE OUR TEENS FOR NOT
IMMERSED IN TOXIC CULTURES THAT
NORMALIZES VIOLENCE AND INSTEAD
ENCOURAGES. HEALTHIER
RELATIONSHIPS I WANT TO THANK
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO
END DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FOR
SPONSORING THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION AND THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS MEMBERS WHO ALSO CO
AUTHORED THIS RESOLUTION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS S. C. R. NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IS A PROUD
CO AUTHOR OF S. C. R. NINE
WHICH DESIGNATES FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION MONTH TEEN DATING
VIOLENCE IS A SERIOUS ISSUE
IMPACTING FAR TOO MANY
CALIFORNIA YOUTH. ACCORDING TO
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION NEARLY ONE IN
ELEVEN FEMALE TEENS AND ONE IN
FIFTEEN MALE TEENS REPORT
HAVING EXPERIENCED PHYSICAL
DATING VIOLENCE IN THE LAST
YEAR. THE CHAIR OF SENATE
EDUCATION I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SO THAT WE
CAN ALL LEARN HOW TO RECOGNIZE
THE WARNING SIGNS. THIS TYPE OF
ABUSE IS TRULY DAMAGING AND
LONG LASTING. IT CAN CONTAIN
CLUED REDUCED ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT INCREASED
LIKELIHOOD THAT VICTIMS WILL
SMOKE OR USE DRUGS. DRUGS
ENGAGE IN UNHEALTHY DIETING A
RISKY SEXUAL BEHAVIORS. I READ
SOMETHING VERY INTERESTING READ
RECENTLY. AND IT SAYS THIS.
DON'T TELL YOUR DAUGHTER THAT
WHEN A BOY IS MEAN OR RUDE TO
HER IT'S BECAUSE HE HAS A CRUSH
ON HER. DON'T TELL HER THAT
ABUSE IS A SIGN OF LOVE. I HOPE
YOU'LL ALL JOIN ME TODAY IN
WORKING TOWARDS A WORLD WHERE
NO YOUNG PEOPLE WILL EVER
EXPERIENCED THIS ABUSE. BY AN
AYE VOTE ON IS HERE NINE. THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER. ZERO MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE AS THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF F.
E. R. NINE. DATA SHOWS THAT IF
YOU ARE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
ENGAGE IN. VIOLENCE TOWARDS
YOUR PARTNER AS AN ADOLESCENT
FOR YOUR AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
EXPERIENCED SUCH VIOLENCE WHEN
WE REFER TO THIS VIOLENCE WE'RE
NOT REFERRING ONLY TO PHYSICAL
YOU'RE REFERRING TO ALSO
INTIMIDATION COERCIVE CONTROL
AND OTHER FORMS OF IN FACT
DOMINANCE OVER PARTNER. THAT
THAT DATA INDICATES THAT A
FIFTEEN. ANYONE WHO EITHER
EXPERIENCES IT OR ACT UPON IT
AT THAT AGE IS FAR MORE LIKELY
TO CONTINUE TO BEHAVIOR EITHER
AS THE VICTIM OR AS THE
PERPETRATOR SO THE SOONER THAT
WE CAN INTERVENE INTERJECT AND
STOP THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR. AND
HELP. HELLO THE YOUNG PERSON
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS THAT IS
DRIVING WHAT UNDERLYING
CIRCUMSTANCES DRIVING THAT
BEHAVIOUR THE MORE LIKELY WE
WILL HAVE. ADULTS WHO ARE NOT
ENGAGED IN THAT AND ADULTS WHO
ARE NOT VICTIM TO IT SO IT IS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS WE JUST PAY
ATTENTION TO LATER IN LIFE- I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT AS DOES
THE WOMEN'S POCKETS AND I AFTER
I DON'T. THANK YOU SIR SENATOR
EGGMAN. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS- I RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE LGBT CAUCUS TO SAY. THAT
TEEN VIOLENCE HAPPENS ACROSS
ACROSS GENDERS ACROSS
RELATIONSHIPS L. G. B. T. Q.
KIDS ARE EVEN MORE AT RISK FOR
THIS BECAUSE THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO NOT BE OUT TO THEIR
FAMILIES 
TALK TO AND TO BE ABLE TO
SUFFER IN SILENCE. THE ABUSE
CAN TAKE FORMS OF PHYSICAL
MENTAL AND AS WELL AS THREATEN
PEOPLE ABOUT THEIR THEIR
PRIVACY AND THEN COMING OUT AND
BEING ADDED. IT IS- IT IS A
PLETHORA OF ISSUES THAT LGBTQ
YOUTH FACE SO AS WE STAND. UP
AGAINST TEEN VIOLENCE DATING
VIOLENCE MAYBE ALSO REMEMBER TO
INCLUDE. ALL OF US WHO WHO WHO
COULD BE SUFFERING THIS AND
AGAIN TO MAKE SURE THAT WE LOOK
OUT FOR OUR OUR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE I STRONGLY OCCURRED
AND COURAGE I ON S. C. R. NINE.
THE CENTER SO PAN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION I THINK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM BALDWIN PARK
FOR RAISING THIS- A LOT OF VERY
IMPORTANT THINGS A VERY BEEN
SAID ABOUT THE TOPIC OF THIS
RESOLUTION I JUST WANTED TO
CREATE KNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT-
WE NEED TO SPEAK OUT ABOUT THIS
THAT THE PROMISE OF SILENCE.
THAT IS A PEDIATRICIAN I KNOW
THAT WHEN I SEE HIM ON EIGHTEEN
PATIENTS- NOW SOMETIMES EVEN IN
THAT SETTING- TEENS DON'T WANT
TO STOP AND TALK ABOUT TODAY
THINK THAT WE DON'T WANNA
LISTEN ABOUT IT SO IT'S
IMPORTANT WE SPEAK OUT IN THIS
RESOLUTION IS IMPORTANT STEP TO
THAT THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
ENERGY AND I THOUGHT. THANK YOU
SENATOR MEN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION OFFERED BY SENATOR
RUBIO HI TO RESOLUTION IT
HIGHLIGHTS AN ISSUE THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO ME AND
TO MY WIFE JANE JANE HAS
DEDICATED HER CAREER TO
SUPPORTING AND DEFENDING
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHE RUNS THE INITIATIVE TO END
FAMILY VIOLENCE AT UC IRVINE.
AND WHAT SHE TELLS ME ALL THE
TIME IS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
TOO OFTEN MISUNDERSTOOD BY
POLICYMAKERS AND LEGISLATORS
THE REALITY OF TV IS THAT IT
COMES IN MANY FORMS AFFECTS
MANY AGE GROUPS AND SPENT TOO
OFTEN STARTS WITH TEENAGERS ONE
IN THREE HIGH SCHOOL GIRLS WILL
EXPERIENCED TEEN DATING
VIOLENCE WITH FARMS INCLUDING
PHYSICAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
INJURY REPRODUCTIVE COERCION
AND OTHER HORRIFIC FARMS. THESE
CAN HAVE LONG TERM IMPACTS
INCLUDING UNWANTED PREGNANCIES
STDS SUBSTANCE ABUSE DECREASED
LIFETIME WAGES EDUCATIONAL
IMPACTS AND SOMETIMES SUICIDE.
AT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION RECOMMENDS THAT
EDUCATION ON GENDER BASED
VIOLENCE START SHOULD START
BEGINNING DURING ADOLESCENCE
AGES ELEVEN TO FOURTEEN. I
THINK THIS RESOLUTION IS AN
IMPORTANT STATEMENT BY THE
STATE SENATE THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE AND OF.
RECOGNIZING THE PROBLEM OF TEEN
DATING VIOLENCE I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
ALSO. YES MR PRESIDENT I RISE
AS A MEMBER OF THE GRANDMOTHERS
CAUCUS I HAVE A TEN YEAR OLD
AND A TWELVE YEAR OLD SYDNEY IN
SENECA AND I WANT THEM GROWING
UP IN A WORLD WHERE THEY WON'T
BE AFRAID TO GO OUT ON A DATE.
BECAUSE OF POTENTIAL VIOLENCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM S. C. R. NINE.
HEARING CHAIN NINE SENATOR
RUBIO WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR JUST
HIGHLIGHTING SUCH AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO ALL MY COLLEAGUES HERE
AND- ENCOURAGE ALL PARENTS TO
READ DISCUSS TEEN VIOLENCE AND
WHAT A HEALTHY RELATIONSHIP
LOOKS LIKE TO WITH YOUR
CHILDREN YOUR NAME AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
S. C. R. NINE IS ELIGIBLE FOR
A- UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION WOULD USE ANY
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON S. C. R.
NINE. HEARING SHE NOTED NO
OBJECTIONS HIGHS THIRTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
OUR MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
MELENDEZ ARE YOU PREPARED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE RESOLUTION FIVE BY
SENATOR MELENDEZ RELATIVE TO
SLAVERY AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PREVENTION MONTH CENTER
MELENDEZ THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TODAY I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
SENATE RESOLUTION FIVE WHICH
IDENTIFIES JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS SLAVERY AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING PREVENTION MONTH
AND THE CULMINATION OF THAT
AWARENESS WITH NATIONAL FREEDOM
DAY WHICH IS RECOGNIZED
ANNUALLY ON FEBRUARY FIRST. THE
UNITED STATES RECOGNIZES THE
KEY PRINCIPLE OF FREEDOM
THROUGH THE THIRTEENTH
AMENDMENT TO OUR CONSTITUTION
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS IDENTIFIED
AS A FORM OF MODERN DAY SLAVERY
PREVALENT IN AMERICAN ACROSS
THE GLOBE. THIS UNSPEAKABLE
CRIME IS STEADILY ON THE RISE
WITH AN ESTIMATED EIGHT HUNDRED
AND 42% INCREASE OVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS CALIFORNIA BOASTS
THE LARGEST INCREASES IN
REPORTED CASES OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. COVERED CRISIS HAS
EXACERBATED THE IMPACTS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING ON OUR
CHILDREN IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
TODAY WE RECOGNIZE THE IMPACTS
TRAFFICKING HAS AND OUR
DAUGHTERS AND OUR SONS OUR
SISTERS AND BROTHERS. OUR LOVED
ONES WE CARE DEEPLY. WE CAN
WORK ON IN A BIPARTISAN MANNER
TO BRING MORE AWARENESS MORE
FINDING ENFORCEMENT TO THIS
ATTACK ON FREEDOM OF INNOCENT
HUMAN BEINGS. WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON US ON
ANSWER FIVE. IT THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING
THEM MICROPHONES. THIS TOO IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION AND
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
SR. NUMBER FIVE. HEARING SEEN
NINE ICE THIRTY TWO NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON NOW
TO FILE ITEM FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR- CHOI BALK ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS I DON'T.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
THE SENATE RESOLUTION SEVEN BY
SENATOR- CHAU OF VOGUE RELATIVE
TO CALIFORNIA GIRLS AND WOMEN
IN SPORTS WEEK. GEN WELL
TROUBLED THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVEN DECLARES THE
FIRST WEEK OF FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS CALIFORNIA GIRLS
AND WOMEN IN SPORTS WEEK. YOU
PARTICIPATION IN SPORTS IS
LINKED TO MANY POSITIVE SOCIAL
CULTURAL EXPERIENCES INCLUDING
A BOOST TO SELF ESTEEM
CONFIDENCE AND OVERALL WELL
BEING. IT ALSO PROVIDES AN
AVENUE FOR YOU TO DEVELOP
LEADERSHIP SKILLS THAT ARE
USEFUL WELL INTO ADULTHOOD. S.
R. SEVEN ACKNOWLEDGES THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF GIRLS AND
WOMEN IN SPORTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ENCOURAGE
ENCOURAGES ALL POLICY MAKERS.
TO TAKE THE APPROPRIATE
MEASURES TO ENSURE EQUITY IN
SPORTS PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES.
I MYSELF AM BLESSED WITH. THREE
STUDENT ATHLETES TWO OF WHICH
ARE YOUNG FEMALES YOUNG WOMEN.
THE PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL WELL
BEING OF ALL OF OUR CHILDREN IS
INHERENTLY IMPORTANT. I WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT SOLUTIONS
THAT WILL ALLOW OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES TO SAFELY RETURN TO
SPORTS AND LET THEM PLAY. I
HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER TO SUPPORT GIRLS
AND WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA IN
GAUGING AND SPORTS PROGRAMS AND
PHYSICAL ACTIVITIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. TWO NINE
THIS TOO IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION WITH USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL AND SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVEN. HERNICI NINE
HIGHS THIRTY TWO NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO. COMMITTEES
ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE THERE ANY
SENATORS WHAT COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS AT THIS TIME.
CENTER EGGMAN. BUDGET SUB THREE
WILL MEET. AT TE CONCLUSION OF
THIS HEARING THE SESSION.
MOREOVER YOU MAY CHECK OUR
CENTER. THREE ONE NINE ONE
THREE ONE NINE ONE. SENATE SET
THREE WITH A MEANS AND BUDGET
SUB THREE WILL MEET AT-
IMMEDIATE LEE UPON A GERMAN AND
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. IF
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR ATKINS THE JUSTICE
CLEAR. MISTER PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH COLLEAGUES I HOPE
YOU HAVE A SAFE AND WONDERFUL
EXTENDED WEEKEND AND
CELEBRATION OF PRESIDENTS DAY.
AND WITH THAT THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
TUESDAY FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT TWO PM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEMBERS
NOT ONLY ENJOY PRESIDENT'S DAY
BUT VALENTINE'S DAY AS WELL THE
SENATE WILL BE RECESSED UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME IT
GERMAN MOTION WILL BE MADE WE
WILL RECONVENE ON TUESDAY. AT
TWO PM.